let me ask have have you guys had frog
legs good question uh I don't think so
no uhuh I would try it I I I'm a picky
eater I don't eat a lot of stuff but I
will try every like for the most part
unless it's like you know the ballute or
whatever but I will really you would try
B uh-uh that's no I actually don't think
I think you'd surprise yourself it
depend it depends where it would have to
be but like it's [__] terrible yeah
that's what I mean I only know it bad
from him he's a quite a picky eater he's
actually not as Asian as we would like
him to be oh my God that's he ate a dead
baby duck he's too much Asian that's
like entry that's like entry level for
Asians but I actually think I mean even
George liked it everyone else liked it
but him I
you're that's prettyy you're pretty come
on dude what do you
think no ballute is a is a Filipino
delicacy in an acquired taste that is
pretty hardcore for yeah but there's
different levels right so you can have
like the older we already has the
feather feather BS and the face and the
beak the feather you when you taste
feather and you crunch into the beak and
then and then the the skull you bite in
the skull and the eyeball pops into your
throat imagine that Dad yeah delicious I
love it that's fine oh look at that one
that looks like Jurassic
Park Dino
DNA hey everybody Bobby Le is about to
EIT me and my eyeballs going to squirt
into the back of his more just like the
visual that's difficult but like taste
alone it's milder than you there we go
that's what we do we change the visual
of it yeah they could put on a cracker
or something I would eat if they could
the flavor down and you put one of those
potato roll or something minion minion
goggles yeah right overalls cute it up
dude up a little bit yeah yeah yeah make
it like a piece of candy or something
yeah yeah anyway um and and that's so
insulting I'm very Asian you don't know
how to cook rice that's like also
another entry level but the emperor
probably didn't know how to do it back
in the day in the you have rice cooker I
do have one what's the rice ratio ratio
oh let's go with ceros the r one cup of
rice one cup of water do you rinse it I
he feels very I rinse it three times do
you really do I do do I've never seen
you cook rice I [__] that's so insulting
I know what to do I'll make rice right
now
[__] I'll make it right now [__] give
me the [__] scooper dude what's the
rice finger show me what do you mean the
rice fingers when you don't have
measurements how do you know the water
to rice ratio I go cup cup no no no no
cups available just eyeball how do you
do it with your hands the rice I'm not a
caveman also where are you going to be
cooking rice when you don't have a
cup just in bare grill it's ins Saye
what no it's a rice ratio you it has to
be a certain it's called a rice finger
for a reason that's how you me the water
I mean you know how to make meatloaf
that's it yeah of course oh that's the
technique it's always the first digit do
you guys know how to make rice yeah uh
[Music]
yeah you know that system no I have a
kitchen that I make it in I don't I'm
not out in the Wilder is guessing I know
that's what I'm saying yeah right so
that's insulting I'll make rice right
now I don't I know the finger ratio just
from my girlfriend's family she's my
girlfriend's Filipino well from Hawaii
so oh she's from Hawaii yeah I said did
have you had ballute then no okay not
yet you but you would I don't know if I
would to be honest with you little baby
duck I mean if I was
starving there we go I'd eat your
fingers you know what I mean yeah yeah
in a starving situation yes these guys
would eat it yes okay yeah but if we end
up going there to see her family I you
know probably would could yeah yeah is
is she the love of your life yeah that's
Bobby Bobby to the Philippines and tell
him how great it is over there it's so
he told us on the podcast podcast and we
were all grossed out what did he share
he shared a couple stories and I said
I'll never going what I did no yeah it's
a beautiful island series of islands
we're talking about ballute